a lot of late night hosts out there and
they're terrific
but they come out and they just tell
some monologue jokes okay that's what
they do they all tell monologue jokes
and uh after a while it seems i don't
know sort of like the same thing again
and again
me i like to innovate sorry other hosts
that's just me
i'm an innovator great pioneer some say
the bravest man in the history of the
world
here's what i've done i found a way to
tell amazing topical jokes
that adds excitement and sex appeal to
the monologue
yeah check this out so uh
reading the paper today scientists say
that one side effect from covid19
is that the brain ages about 10 years
yeah
so that would uh make donald trump a 12
year old
yet another epic takedown is not for the
faint of heart
who knew that a string of words
nice one yeah no problem andy
hey check this out people are
complaining that tbs cut off the ending
of jingle all the way before the movie
was completely over
yeah people complained because they
wanted tbs to cut off the movie
way earlier oh my god we can't stop
laughing pants are soaked from coast to
coast
just in wisdom harmonizing this late
night oh
in this version you look like large
marge from peewee's big adventure
large marge from peewee's remember the
truck driver yeah yeah
yeah like because your hairness is going
straight up
hey ikea announced it will no longer
publish
its catalog hey i'm sorry but that's
just
[ __ ] up when you find a little
laughing
at a punchline so perfect bow down to
your tv and with
tears of respect
how has this singer actually heard these
jokes i mean
i don't seem connected exactly
the singer was supposed to read all the
jokes thoroughly beforehand
a new study found that taking a walk
when it's dark out is good for you
yeah the study was sponsored by
murderers
how many more of these will he do singer
must be getting tired
still he'd better sing he trusts let's
dig in fire
uh where did we even find this singer oh
he just offered to do it because
apparently he's a huge fan
actually it was on craigslist i found
conan's desperate plea
he agreed to pay for gas and let our jet
our hobbies
well enough of that gem
you know